[Musik]
und jetzt das heute journal mit Hanna
Zimmermann und Christian Sievers guten
Abend ihnen allen wir beginnen mit einer
epochalen Verschiebung in dieser Welt
die immer noch am öltropf hängt die
Reichen Ölstaaten am Golf stehen vor der
Wahl ein Zeichen für Menschenrechte und
gegen den Krieg zu setzen oder lieber
noch reichere Ölstaaten zu werden was
glauben Sie wie die sich entscheiden
das ist eine rhetorische Frage denn die
Entscheidung liegt auf dem Tisch und sie
ist für die westliche Welt eine Ohrfeige
die zunehmend verzweifelt wirkenden
Reisen westlicher Staatenlenker zuletzt
des Bundeskanzlers an den Golf waren
rückblickend nicht viel wert der
US-Präsident will jetzt die gesamte
jahrzehntelange Zusammenarbeit mit
Saudi-Arabien überdenken denn das
förderkartell der OPEC arbeitet künftig
einem gewissen Vladimir Putin in die
Hände der Präsident der Vereinigten
Arabischen Emirate ist heute in Russland
Sebastian eben berichtet
wie wichtig der heutige Staatsgast für
Vladimir Putin ist kann man am Auto
erkennen Mohammed binzayed darf in einer
edle Limousine aus der regierungsgarage
zu Putin fahren und das in dessen
Heimatstadt St Petersburg eine besondere
Ehre für Putin kommt der Staatsbesuch
genau richtig denn er will zeigen wie
eng er mit den OPEC-Staaten
zusammenarbeitet und wie viel er bei der
Ölfördermenge mitzureden hat
unsere Entscheidungen unsere Aktionen
sind nicht gegen irgendwen gerichtet wir
handeln nicht um irgendwem Probleme zu
bereiten
es ist ein zynischer Satz von dem Putin
weiß dass er den Westen erzürnen wird
ein weiterer Schlag in die Magengrube
mitten in der Energiekrise
denn erst vor einer Woche hatten die
erdölfördernden Länder für einen eklar
gesorgt die OPEC unter ihnen
Saudi-Arabien Iran und die Vereinigten
Arabischen Emirate sowie deren
Erweiterung die sogenannte opec-plus
darunter Russland hatten beschlossen die
gemeinsame erdöl-fördermenge zu kürzen
um täglich etwa 320 Millionen Liter die
USA eigentlich ein enger Verbündeter der
opec-führungsmacht Saudi-Arabien zeigten
sich entsetzt
das ist eine Enttäuschung wir schauen
uns nach Alternativen um
die Folge der Verknappung der Ölpreis
steigt und sorgt zum Beispiel für
teureres Benzin vor allem für die USA
kommt das zur Unzeit die Zwischenwahlen
stehen an und teures Benzin heißt
wütende Wähler dabei war Joe Biden erst
im Juli in Saudi-Arabien kumpelhafter
fistbump mit einem geächteten die
Vorwürfe gegen Kronprinz bin Salman nach
dem Mord am Journalisten kaschocki
stehen immer noch im Raum doch beiden
braucht das Öl nur drei Monate später
folgt auf die freundschaftliche
faustbegrüßung der Schlag ins Gesicht
Saudi-Arabien wendet sich Russland zu
kauft dort sogar Öl für die eigene
Stromerzeugung und stärkt damit die
Kreml Finanzen in Sankt Petersburg
verdeutlicht heute auch der Präsident
der Vereinigten Arabischen Emirate wie
eng die Beziehungen zu Russland sind
und haben eine Millionen Touristen aus
Russland besucht all das haben wir nur
mit der Hilfe Russlands geschafft
für die Kameras des Staatsfernsehens
gibt sich Vladimir Putin zum Abschied
des Präsidenten freundschaftlich der
frierende Gast bekommt eine Jacke
geschenkt niemand soll daran zweifeln
dass das Verhältnis zwischen Russland
und den op-ländern warm und herzlich ist
er bekommt tatsächlich eine Jacke
geschenkt da verschiebt sich enorm etwas
und es sind keine guten Nachrichten für
den Westen der Energieexperte Andreas
goldhau ist bei uns von der Deutschen
Gesellschaft für auswärtige Politik
guten Abend Herr Professor schönen Abend
Herr Sievers versetzen wir uns doch mal
kurz in die Situation der Opec-Länder
geht's denen einfach nur darum noch
reicher zu werden nun vordergründig geht
es der OPEC Momentum die Preise zu
stabilisieren denn der die Preise haben
sich nach unten entwickelt von noch 130
Dollar im Juni jetzt auf 90 das ist
Abwärtstrend der gestoppt werden muss
und das zeigt eben die Aktion der OPEC
im letzten in der letzten Woche
allerdings ist natürlich das politische
Signal dass sehr viel wichtigere und das
wurde ja auch im Beitrag schon
angesprochen hier ist letzten Endes den
begehrter westlichen Staaten nicht
stattgegeben worden
es wäre für beiden wichtig gewesen mit
Blick auf die Mitte im elections einen
einigermaßen moderaten Ölpreis zu
bekommen Wladimir Putins Einnahmen
sollten nach unten gefahren werden und
gleichzeitig natürlich die restliche
Länder von der Ruhe und Energie
induzierten Inflation geplagt und das
sind also die Symbolik und und das sieht
ja anal war jetzt natürlich nein wir
selbst stellen es um die Seite von Putin
nicht an eure Seite und warum machen die
das was ist der Grund dahinter was ist
der Grund auch für diesen Bruch und für
für die Tatsache dass die Bemühungen um
eine weltweite Ächtung des russischen
Präsidenten ja damit komplett
unterlaufen werden ich glaube da steckt
auch eine gewisse Verschiebung in der
energiegeographie Global dahinter das
Epizentrum der Weltwirtschaft wandert
nach Osten dort sind die dynamischsten
Wirtschaften der Zukunft dort findet die
meiste Energie Nachfrage statt und die
OPEC orientiert sich sukzessive nach
Osten und weiß natürlich auch dort
liegen ihre Märkte der Westen wird
weniger wichtig wird die Karbonisieren
spätestens in den 30er Jahren wollen
keine Kohle kein Gast kein Öl mehr und
für die OPEC ist natürlich wichtig zu
schauen wo sind die zündungsmärkte von
morgen deswegen wir weniger wichtig
China Indien mehr und die Orientierung
findet im Moment statt das trifft uns
testen natürlich zum absolut
ungünstigsten Zeitpunkt den man sich
überhaupt vorstellen kann welche
Optionen haben wir denn jetzt bleiben
wir vielleicht mal beim US-Präsidenten
der jetzt ja ganz dringend haben wir
gehört vor den Zwischenwahlen billige
Benzinpreise für die amerikanere braucht
welche Optionen hat er
nun im Moment ist es ja so dass der
Ölpreis sich eher zur Seite bewegt das
heißt also wir haben ein stabil hohen
Ölpreis
wenn man den nach unten bekommen möchte
hat man zwei Optionen ist eine man
verbraucht weniger das andere man wirft
mehr Öl auf den Markt und da haben die
Amerikaner ja schon in der Vergangenheit
reagiert und etwas von ihrer
strategischen Ölreserve angezapft das
kann man in der Tat wieder tun ist
allerdings ein recht kurzfristiger
Effekt und und wird auch nicht
langfristig eine Wirkung auf dem Markt
erzählen letzten Endes bleibt nur eines
weg von den fossilen rein in die
Erneuerbaren Alternativen schaffen ist
das jetzt ein historischer Keil der sich
da in die eigentlich doch sehr sehr enge
Zusammenarbeit zwischen den Golfstaaten
insbesondere zwischen Saudi-Arabien und
den USA schieb welche dauerhaften Folgen
wird das denn haben
Fazit in der Tat so aus denn in der Tat
war es ja eine Zeit lang eine sehr
symbiotische Beziehung die Amerikaner
schaffen für Sicherheit schenken die
fünfte Flotte in den Golf stellen sicher
das Exporte von Öl stattfinden können
und gleichzeitig liefern diese Audis
auch während Zeiten in denen schwierig
ist die Golfkriege und andere
vergleichbare Krisen das ist etwas das
jetzt gerade ins Rutschen kommt in der
Tat und hier verschiebt sich etwas die
diese alte symbiotische Beziehung
scheint in der Tat in Skripten zu raten
geraten und die saudische Regierung hat
anscheinend so sieht es aus das Blatt
hier bereits
es verschiebt sich etwas und wir waren
zumindest von außen mit dabei auch wenn
es uns ganz besonders betreffen wird
ganz herzlichen Dank für diese Expertise
heute abend Professor goldhau Uni Erfurt
vielen Dank für bei uns waren sehr gerne
ja das ist das ganz große Bild das uns
wirklich noch beschäftigen wird in den
Städten der Ukraine zeigt sich heute was
ganz offensichtlich Strategie ist im
Kreml gezielt die
Energieinfrastruktur zu treffen und
neben Elektrizitätswerken wie das das
gestern in Lemberg ausbrannte werden
zunehmend auch wieder Wohnhäuser
bombardiert keine Bleibe und kein Strom
das ist die bittere Realität in vielen
Orten je mehr zerstört ist desto härter
wird der Winter in der Ukraine das
dürfte das zynische Kalkül dahinter sein
wie sich die Menschen vorbereiten
versuchen sich vorzubereiten das
beschreibt unsere Reporterin Alisa jung
jetzt noch hat Kiew einen sonnigen
Herbst aber die Kälte wird kommen
vor zwei Jahren hat Sergi Kocak Salewski
diese Terrasse gebaut eigentlich um
draußen mit Freunden zu sitzen und zu
grillen jetzt mauert er sie zu um es im
Winter wärmer zu haben
du musst morgen
ich werde so um die 15 bis 20 Prozent an
Heizkosten sparen
ziemlich günstige Lösung die sich viele
leisten könnten trotz der gestiegenen
Baukosten
es ist ein guter dilum in der Zukunft zu
sparen
ich werde wohl in einer Woche damit
fertig sein
er wohnt im Norden von Kiew in Novi PI
trifft sie die Russen standen am
Kriegsbeginn 10 km vor seiner Haustür
nun will er vorbereitet sein was auch
immer noch kommen mag mit dem 24 Februar
haben wir gelernt immer einen Eimer
Wasser oder zwei hier zu haben und noch
mehr er hat einen Generator gekauft er
funktioniert
er kann gleichzeitig den Kühlschrank den
Wasserkocher und das Licht am Laufen
halten
Laptops und Smartphones laden
außerdem heize ich das Haus mit einem
Gasboiler
aber der läuft auch nicht ohne Strom
am Montag nach dem Angriff der Russen
auf Kiew kam der Generator gleich zum
Einsatz Stromausfall über mehrere
Stunden
und Laptops zu laden
und wir haben zusammen auf einem
Gaskocher gekocht richtig leckere
Kartoffeln
ganz ohne elektrisches Licht wir haben
mehrere Kerzen aufgestellt das hat uns
erinnert an unsere traditionellen Feste
wenn es dunkel ist und nur Kerzen an das
könnte Ihnen hier nun öfter passieren
nach Angriffen auf die kritische
Infrastruktur will der
Stromnetzbetreiber von Kiew nun
vorbeugen um das Netz stabil zu halten
um uns auf die Herbst Wintersaison
vorzubereiten hat unser Unternehmen
Zeitpläne erstellt für Notfälle und
kontrollierte Stromabschaltung über
mehrere Stunden
das könnte ein kalter und dunkler Winter
werden viele können nur hoffen ein so
gut vorbereiteten Nachbarn wie es Sergi
zu haben
das stimmt wir wissen nicht wie es
weitergeht aber wenn die Versorgung mit
Strom und Wärme zunehmend schwierig wird
wenn immer unklarer ist wo man noch
halbwegs sicher sein kann dann ist eins
klar die Zahl der Menschen die aus der
Ukraine zu uns kommen nimmt noch mal zu
und auch bei uns bringt die Zahl der
Flüchtlinge manche Städte an ihre
Grenzen bundesweit gab es dieses Jahr
schon 35 Prozent mehr Anträge auf Asyl
als im selben Zeitraum im Vorjahr aber
deutlich weniger als etwa noch 2015/16
allerdings kommen dazu noch die
Flüchtlinge aus der Ukraine die kein
Asylverfahren brauchen viel zu
besprechen und idealerweise zu
beschließen also auf dem
flüchtlingsgipfel heute Klaus Brodbeck
an szenen wie diese dürfte sich
Deutschland wieder gewöhnen müssen
geflüchtete aus der Ukraine wenn dort
Putins Krieg und eisiger Winter den
Menschen noch mehr zusetzen es ist genau
das worauf sich bunt Länder und Kommunen
vorbereiten in aller Eile die Zahlen der
Jahre 2015 und 16 sind bereits
übertroffen das Chaos von damals aber
soll sich trotz der Krisensituation
nicht wiederholen wir haben uns ganz
konkret von meiner Stadt zu sagen zwei
Zeltstädte repariert in Dresden ist eine
Messehalle gemietet das heißt die
Situation insgesamt der geflüchteten
Menschen hat eine Größenordnung erreicht
die sehr wohl vergleichbar ist mit den
Jahren 15 und 16 wenn sie Ukraine
geflüchtete Menschen plus weiter
Asylsuchende hinzuziehen dann zeigt dass
die Herausforderung vor der wir stehen
schon rüsten Städte und Gemeinden wieder
Turnhallen um Notquartiere nicht nur für
Menschen aus der ukra auch aus Syrien
Afghanistan Irak der Türkei und Afrika
kommen wieder mehr leerstehende
Einrichtungen des Bundes sollen die
Raumnot lindern
wir haben zudem Plätze für mehr als
64.000 Menschen in bundesimmobilien
bereitgestellt haben dort auch noch
Kapazitäten übrig und haben heute
zusätzlich ganz konkret 56 weitere
bundesimmobilien Angeboten für die
Unterbringung vor Ort die Zusammenarbeit
von Bund Ländern und Gemeinden soll
besser werden eine digitale Plattform
geflüchtete auf Unterkünfte verteilen
mehr Transparenz zeitweilige
Aufnahmestopps sind gleich mehreren
Bundesländern hatten für Ärger gesorgt
dass sei vorbei im Moment
es kann kein Bundesland bei uns
akzeptieren dass sich jeweils ein Land
sozusagen zu Lasten der anderen aus
dieser Solidarität verabschiedet
verschärfte Grenzkontrollen hier
Tschechiens zur Slowakei aber auch
entlang Deutschlands Grenzen zu
Tschechien und Österreich sollen den
Zustrom über die Balkanroute dämpfen
immer mehr versuchen es über Serbien die
Regierung in Belgrad verlangt keine Visa
und schickt geflüchtete weiter nach
Europa um es klar zu sagen die
visapraxis Serbiens ist inakzeptabel
auch diese trägt zu den Bewegungen auf
der Balkanroute bei ein Land wie Serbien
das sehr Mitglied der EU werden will
früher oder später kann sich gegenüber
den anderen europäischen Ländern nicht
so verhalten beim europäischen
flüchtlingsgipfel kommenden Freitag will
Faeser den Druck auf die serbische
Regierung erhöhen so oder so der Druck
auf Deutschland und Europa bleibt
Fragen zum Thema an Sachsens
Innenminister Armin Schuster hat meine
Kollegin Gundula Gause nachher im
heute-journal Update aber erst du jetzt
Hannah in St Petersburg haben sich der
russische Präsident Putin und der Chef
der Internationalen Atomenergiebehörde
grossi getroffen dabei ging es um die
Sicherheit des ukrainischen
Atomkraftwerk saporicia Putin erklärte
offen für Dialog zu sein grossy forderte
eine Schutzzone um das AKW und
bezeichnete die Situation als zunehmend
gefährlich das von Russland besetzte
atomkraftwerkgerät immer wieder unter
Beschuss
Bundeskanzler Scholz hat den gestern
vorgelegten Vorschlag der
Expertenkommission zur gaspreisbremse
als sehr sehr gute Grundlage bezeichnet
politiker von Union aber auch von SPD
und Grünen sehen allerdings Potenzial
zur Nachbesserung
CSU-Landesgruppenchef Dobrindt
kritisierte die Bremse müsse früher
kommen
SPD-Fraktionschef Mütze nicht erklärte
dass die Einmalzahlung im Dezember
eventuell nicht ausreiche morgen wird
der Bundestag in einer aktuellen Stunde
über die Vorschläge debattieren
die Ampelkoalition streitet weiter über
die Laufzeitverlängerung der deutschen
Atomkraftwerke
Bundeswirtschaftsminister Habeck warf
der FDP die Blockade eines
Gesetzentwurfs vor was den Weiterbetrieb
gefährden würde dies wies die FDP zurück
Fraktionschef dürr erklärte haarbacks
Zeitplan die Laufzeitverlängerung schon
nächste Woche im Bundestag zu
verabschieden könne eingehalten werden
während die Grünen nur zwei AKW für
begrenzte Zeit in reserverhalten wollen
fordert die FDP unter anderem einen
deutlich längeren Weiterbetrieb aller
drei verbliebenen AKW
nach jahrzehntelangem Streit haben
Israel und der Libanon sich nun auf den
Verlauf ihrer Seegrenze im Mittelmeer
geeinigt dabei ging es vor allem um den
Zugang zu offshore Gasfeldern der durch
die Einigung nun geklärt ist für beide
Länder ist dies ein wichtiger Schritt
israel hatte zugesagt mehr Gas nach
Europa zu exportieren dem Libanon könnte
die könnten die Gewinne aus der
Gasförderung helfen die eigene
Wirtschaftskrise zu bewältigen beide
Seiten müssen das Abkommen noch
unterzeichnen
wenn man Israelis nach iron Dome fragt
dem hocheffektiven raketenschutzschirm
für ihr Land dann hört man dafür lohne
sich jeder einzelne Schekel die Ukraine
bräuchte ein anderes System angepasst an
ein viel größeres Gebiet Millionen
Menschen wären dankbar wenn die G7
Staaten ein solches mithelfen würden
aufzubauen appelliert heute der
ukrainische Präsident an die wichtigsten
westlichen Industriestaaten die zum
virtuellen Gipfel verabredet sind
währenddessen meldet der Spiegel aus
Deutschland ist zumindest eines von vier
zugesagten hochmodernen Abwehrsystemen
in der Ukraine angekommen Florian euern
es geht weiter immer weiter hier backmut
in der Ostukraine dort Kiew eine
U-Bahn-Station in der Hauptstadt
Menschen suchen Schutz vor
unmenschlichen
derweil im Brüsseler Hauptquartier der
NATO eine Frage an den Generalsekretär
ob er angesichts eines Krieges bei dem
auf jede Eskalation die nächste folgt
noch ruhig schlafen können
ich habe immer gut schlafen können auch
in Krisenzeiten oder bei schwierigen
Aufgaben aber ich bin besorgt wenn ich
den andauernden Krieg in der Ukraine
sehe und das Leid und die Bereitschaft
Putins brutale Gewalt gegen eine
souveräne unabhängige demokratische
Nation wie die Ukraine anzuwenden
der Krieg im achten Monat die nuklearen
Drohungen des russischen Präsidenten von
Monat zu Monat schärfer und der Westen
ist sich nicht mehr ganz so sicher dass
das bloß ein Bluff ist so vor wir haben
sie any changes bislang haben wir keine
Veränderungen in der nuklearen
Aufstellung Russlands festgestellt aber
wir bleiben wachsam und natürlich müssen
wir es ernst nehmen wenn eine atomacht
so kommuniziert wie es Putin gerade tut
es ist die Art von Drohung die den
Westen zerreißen könnte ein knicken um
den Atomkrieg abzuwenden oder sich nicht
erpressen lassen
wenn eine explizite nukleardrung erfolgt
dann glaube ich dass die Einheit des
Westens aufbricht und das hier
Regierungen gegeneinander stehen ob eine
solche Drohung mit dem Einsatz von
Nuklearwaffen nicht dazu führen soll
dass der Westen die Unterstützung der
Ukraine weitestgehend aufgibt zumindest
vorerst gelingt es dem Westen diesen
Eindruck abzuwenden G7 videogipfel der
Staats- und Regierungschef sollte
Nachmittag zugeschaltet der ukrainische
Präsident am Ende steht eine gemeinsame
Erklärung und die einerseits deutliche
andererseits bewusst unklare Ansage dass
jeder Einsatz chemische biologischer
oder nuklearer Waffen durch Russland
ernste Konsequenzen nach sich ziehen
würde welche mancher spekuliert
dann würden die USA und voraussichtlich
andere Staaten ob die NATO oder eine
Koalition in der Ukraine selbst
eingreifen sodass russland-situation
sich noch einmal verschlechtern würde
für alle Arten von Risiken Bedrohungen
und Herausforderungen ich kann Ihnen
natürlich nicht die Einzelheiten dieser
nato-pläne mitteilen aber seien Sie
sicher dass wir da sind um alle
Verbündeten zu schützen
man hofft dass allein schon die Drohung
in Moskau gehört wird und dass der Strom
an neuen Waffenlieferungen nicht
versiegt morgen reden darüber die NATO
Verteidigungsminister in Brüssel es geht
weiter immer weiter
Tickets weiter mit Johanna
es geht um die Gehälter von rund 2,5
Millionen Beschäftigten in Deutschland
die Gewerkschaften Bär die und der
deutsche Beamten Bund wollen das deren
Löhne kräftig steigen und nun ist auch
klar wie stark genau Frank beetmann in
Frankfurt gefordert werden 10,5% mehr
wie begründet die Gewerkschaften das wer
zum einen selbstverständlich mit der
Teuerung zuletzt lag die Inflation in
Deutschland ja bei 10 Prozent und man
war sich auf der Arbeitnehmerseite schon
einig weniger als ein
Inflationsausgleich solle es nicht sein
hinter den Beschäftigten liegen bereits
zwei Jahre des reallohnverlustes und
eine zu erwartende Preissteigerung ist
signifikant auch für das nächste Jahr
ist und deshalb ist unsere Forderung
absolut realistisch die Arbeitgeberseite
sieht das anders mahnt zur Zurückhaltung
die Energiekreise und die Inflation
haben auch den Kommunen zugesetzt der
Betrieb vieler Einrichtungen sei
erheblich teurer geworden und gerade
während Corona hätten Kommunen
vielerorts deutlich weniger eingenommen
weil die Unternehmen weniger Steuern
gezahlt haben wie geht es denn jetzt
genau weiter in den Verhandlungen wer
zum ersten Mal an den Tisch setzen sich
die Parteien im Januar nach der ersten
Verhandlungsrunde könnten erste
Warnstreiks drohen und da man schon den
Eindruck hat die Vorstellung gehen weit
auseinander ist das Ende Januar mitten
im Winter nicht unwahrscheinlich und man
weiß ja auch wenn Kitas geschlossen
bleiben oder die Müllabfuhr nicht mehr
kommt dann kann das schon das
öffentliche Leben ganz schön
beeinträchtigen vielen Dank Frank für
deine Einschätzung
wie erwartet hat der Internationale
Währungsfonds seine Wachstumsprognose
für die Weltwirtschaft erneut gesenkt
und zwar auf 2,7% für das kommende Jahr
das sind 0,2% Punkte weniger als noch im
Sommer angenommen besonders schlecht
fällt die Prognose dabei für Deutschland
aus die Volkswirtschaft der
Bundesrepublik dürfte laut IWF 2023 um
0,3% schrumpfen auch für Italien wird
eine Rezession vorausgesagt
die NASA testmission bei der die
Flugbahn eines Asteroiden verändert
werden sollte war erfolgreich das gab
die US-Raumfahrtbehörde am Abend bekannt
vor gut zwei Wochen prallte eine
ungefähr Kühlschrank große unbemannte
Sonde auf einen Asteroiden dieser war
übrigens nie eine echte Bedrohung für
die Erde mit der datenmission probt die
NASA allerdings den Ernstfall sollte
tatsächlich ein Asteroid auf die Erde zu
steuern
Traumjob das ist für manche Astronauten
für manche Tauchlehrer im Tropenparadies
für manche ist es gleich nach dem Papst
SPD-Chef zu sein unsere heute journal
Filmkritikerin Sabine Schulz hat
wirklich einen Traumjob sie sitzt den
ganzen Tag im Kino und da ist nun mal
der Ort an dem tatsächlich noch Träume
wahr werden und sie trifft die Stars das
heißt sie traf denn Sabine Schulz hört
auf sie geht in Rente und räumt ihr Büro
und was da an Schätzen zum Vorschein
kommt das zeigen wir Ihnen jetzt die
großen des Films von einer unbekannten
Seite und mit ganz eigenen Gedanken über
diese Welt
sie sind Hollywoodstars oder Kult
Regisseure verehrt vergöttert verklärt
aber wie sind sie wirklich
dies ist eine Geschichte von Begegnungen
persönlichen Eindrücken Überraschungen
ein Blick hinter die Kulissen
diese zwei das aufregendste statuo seit
Robert Redford und Paul Newman hey red
really Newmans
wir glücklichen
von ihm heißt es er sei so wortkarg und
verschlossen wie in seinen frühen
Filmrollen klingt eastwo 2007 auf der
Berlinale nein verschlossen ist er nicht
eher humorvoll gelassen es geht um seine
Regiearbeit letters from evochima über
den Pazifikkrieg aus Sicht der Japaner
ein Antikriegsfilm mit einer liberalen
Friedensbotschaft ausgerichtet von ihm
dem konservativen Republikaner
wie passt das zusammen
haben die friedensbotschaften doch nicht
für sich gepachtet das zeigt vielleicht
meine Vielseitigkeit
Anthony Hopkins mit einer erstaunlichen
these im Zusammenhang mit seiner Rolle
als Picasso in Liebesbeziehungen sei
Picasso ein Monster gewesen sagte
großzügig war er nur zu Fremden aber das
ist so ein Paradox des menschlichen
Wesens an sich wir sind doch alle viel
netter zu Fremden als zu unseren
Partnern
zur Beziehung zwischen Mann und Frau hat
sie eine klare Meinung die
temperamentvolle Emma Thompson ist immer
ein Erlebnis
wir müssen unsere Machtstrukturen ändern
wir sind viel komplexer als das
Rollenklischee vom machoman und der
püppchenfrau
lasst uns nach vorne schauen und neue
Geschichten erzählen
die Suche nach neuen Geschichten beginnt
auf den Filmfestivals kann ein Kapitel
für sich Filmkunst Commerz und Spektakel
ein verspielter Bruce Willis
soll das der taffe Typ sein aus den
Macho filmen
ich trage oft Frauenkleider
das Kino und seine Helden
Stimmungsaufheller Mutmacher und
manchmal gelingt es ihnen einen Ort zu
schaffen zum träumen von einer besseren
Welt
[Musik]
ja und diese Orte brauchen wir alle
gerade mehr denn je
alles geben für eine Leidenschaft damit
geht es bei uns im ZDF-Programm gleich
weiter im nächsten Jahr ist Breakdance
zum ersten Mal bei Olympia dabei die 37
Grad Reportage begleitet zwei junge
Menschen die ihrerseits alles daran
setzen damit zu machen mein Tanz mein
Battle gleich hier im ZDF und wir
verabschieden uns für heute und wünschen
Ihnen einen angenehmen Abend
[Musik]
guten Abend am Mittelmeer liegen die
Temperaturen noch bei sommerlichen 25
bis 35 Grad bei uns in Mitteleuropa ist
es kühler und heute Nacht wird es kalt
in der Mitte hier da sinken die
Temperaturen auf plus drei bis minus ein
Grad dort droht also verbreitet
Bodenfrost deutlich milder bleibt die
Nacht am warmen Wasser mit 10 oder 8
Grad oder auch in Süddeutschland bei 9
bis 8 Grad das liegt dort an dichteren
Wolken die auch in der Nacht noch etwas
Regen mitbringen in der Mitte bildet
sich wieder dicker Nebel und mit dem
haben wir es auch morgen früh erstmal zu
tun dann löst er sich auf und hier
scheint häufig die Sonne am ehesten
stark bewölkt bleibt es ja an der
Ostseeküste dazu kommt der Wind in
Norddeutschland meist aus südlichen
Richtern anders sieht es am Alpenrand
aus da kommt der Wind aus Nordost da
gibt es dann dichtere Wolken da kann es
auch noch ein bisschen regnen ähnlich
wie heute liegen morgen die
Höchsttemperaturen bei uns in
Deutschland bei 14 Grad auf Rügen und 20
Grad am Neckar oder auch am Oberrhein
und danach wird es erstmal nicht sich
großartig ändern bei den Temperaturen
selbst übernehmen die Regie es wird also
wechselhafter aber zur kommenden Woche
da kommt es noch mal richtig warm von
Südwesten zu uns da könnten die
Temperaturen noch mal eine Anleihe bei
den sommerwerten machen das sehen wir
hier ganz gut das ist erstmal bei diesen
Temperaturen bleibt Donnerstag Freitag
Samstag bei 13 bis 19 Grad aber am Trend
für Freiburg im Breisgau sehen sie
Anfang der kommenden Woche könnten noch
mal 25 Grad erreicht werden und auch die
Nächte werden deutlich milder mit 10 bis
15 Grad